thanks about all those who came along to
my earlier the keynote earlier on I have
made some improvements to my setup so
hopefully now you're able to see my
screen and my video I had to
there's some things involving network
cables I do not want to go into because
the sysadmin in me wants to cry about
the setup that is being jury-rigged here
to make all of this work but hopefully
I'm coming across very clear and that
you're enjoying this probably self
isolating at home oh we're now going
talking a bit about our micro services
and how they relate to the concept of
service service is a big hype topic and
I think rightly so actually and we're
gonna be exploring a little bit about
what services but talking about service
and specifically function as a service
in the context of micro service
architectures as before we will be using
slide o for questions so if you want to
go and ask the questions during a talk
Yunel - as slide though and use the
hashtag k-y eight six zero
that's why eight six zero and that will
allow you to ask questions as we go do
you want to go to that website now open
up in a window so needed you can keep it
open you can keep it refreshing and just
ask questions as you as we go through
the session and that will give you a lot
of things to answer when we end I'm not
going to talk about the work I do in the
books I've really started that in the
keynote but if you don't know more about
you know decomposing - - micro services
and all that sort of stuff you can find
information about all of that and my
books and the services that I offer for
my company over on my website though
we're here to talk about service and
micro services so we should talk a
little bit about micro services as I
always draw them these nice hexagonal
architectures and kind of you know you
micro services have become almost
ubiquitous in terms of its that for many
people it's unfortunately become the
default way of building software but
it's sort of its uppermost in our minds
but I do think it's often important to
just refresh that sort of the most
important characteristics of micro
service architectures and you know talk
about these things as being
independently deployable services that
work together
modeled around a business domain so you
know we're taking business
functionality we're packaging it up
together and I'm exposing that business
functionality over network interfaces so
typically talking about one process
talking to another process over some
sort of network boundary although that
kind of blurs a bit when we start moving
into the world of functions but we use
the business domain to define those
service boundaries but the really
important characteristic here is this
idea of independent deployability
and that's a really important facet so
many of the things that we look to get
from micro service architectures
noticing completely the key benefit that
we get with micro architecture is over
other styles of modular architecture is
this idea of independent employability
so we can make a change to a service we
can deploy that service into a
production environment without
necessarily having impact on the rest of
the wider system this can make it easier
for teams to work in isolation or more
previa tana meet of teams so you know
your team can work with your service by
itself they can make decisions about
when to deploy this also works really
well when you're trying to you know get
teams to own more of the end-to-end sort
of operational responsibilities for your
software
hopefully it also means is that you can
get you can have more developers working
on a problem without getting in each
other's ways so if you know if if you
could sort of break apart the different
parts of your overall product or the
overall system give those two different
teams to own and manage if their
services are also created in a micro
service style they can be changed and
evolved independently from each other
and that's a that's a really important
idea and then this idea of autonomy of
it sort of firm cut through a lot of
what we were looking at for micro
service architectures James Lewis who
these early people looking into micro
services he wrote the original article
over at Larsson Fowler's website now
he's saying that Michaelis says so that
micro services are in architecture which
optimized for autonomy and so by picking
a micro service architecture we're sort
of saying that autonomy is really
important to us and so we're gonna pick
micro services because hopefully it can
allow us to go faster work more in
parallel its interest
and this idea of sort of empowering
teams and allowing teams to own more
responsibilities you know it cuts across
a lot of the shifts we've seen in IT
development over the last 20 years if
you think about the public cloud for
example I touched on this in my keynote
a big part of the public cloud is about
allowing direct self-service access so
rather than having to raise a ticket to
an Operations team and say please can I
have a machine instead you could go to
your own dashboard and click a button to
get it or even better write some code or
use some sort of automated scripts to
spin up the machines that you want as in
public clouds have been credibly useful
in terms of further empowering teams and
giving them more autonomy and to
autonomy here largely through the
ability to sell service other benefits
as well that come with the public cloud
as we touched on in the keynote and
really when you get down to what the
public cloud is it's a succession of
higher or lower you know multiple
abstractions over underlying physical
infrastructure you know you think about
the core sort of infrastructural
building blocks of storage compute
networking rather than actually dealing
with the physical aspects of that we're
working with abstractions that allow us
to reverse abstractions and so we're
dealing with these things at a slightly
higher level I don't have to go and
connect a network cable I could write a
for loop to connect a 10 20 or a million
virtual network connections and at the
base level we first thought probably
third cloud first came out well I said
she's not true but what really caught
the imagination of public cloud early on
was really quite you know the grand
scheme of things low level abstractions
over these three you know these three
primitives of storage compute and
networking we used to talk about the
cloud using these these three these four
letters IaaS infrastructure as a service
so that's what that was the term used to
describe what AWS were offering taken as
it was emit a bit of a misunderstanding
but
nonetheless it's a term that's still in
some widespread use
infrastructure-as-a-service is really
talking about those cloud abstractions
that sort of are quite close to the
physical counterpart right we can
imagine when I connect a an attached
storage device that's like plugging a
disk into a machine and when I open up a
network connection between two machines
is like liking a cable in potentially so
the the analogies between those two
things that are quite similar and of
course you know we've gone from in this
world when we talk about compute in the
space of infrastructure-as-a-service
what we're normally talking about I'm
spinning up a machine what I'm actually
doing is I'm spinning up a virtual
machine sitting on top of physical
infrastructure and to the cloud provider
they call an API to say spit up an ec2
instance on AWS for example well the
scenes what's actually happening is you
know that API call is hitting a
virtualization layer running on their
physical infrastructure and it's
spitting up a virtual machine for me
it's handing the networking and then
passing control over to me and you
notability that from a from a
functionality point of view is quite
similar to what you experienced VMware
albeit with a nicer control plane on top
so that's sort of infrastructures
service and so quite low level and then
we started kicking a bit looking at
other types of abstractions and
containers have become a big hockey fan
scape certainly for people building sort
of systems on top and Linux basis
operating systems containers have been
around for many many years and Windows
actually the story around containers and
windows and Raman it's been getting a
lot better
you know since really 2000 and Windows 7
2016 containers have been supported much
better within the windows ecosystem
although there's still definitely work
to be done in terms of the size of those
containers because you know even with
things like nano server and stuff you
know we still looking at quite large
containers in the windows ecosystem
compared to analytics ecosystem but but
the but you know where we are
it's an improving game but now many
people are thinking about the container
as our unit of deployment which you know
is a slightly higher level abstraction
than on a virtual machine right we sort
of we're dealing with something else now
is sort of dealing with a package
of of operating system and our
application together and that's our now
our unit of deployment whereas before I
would bring up a virtual machine have to
plow the configuration for that virtual
machines operating system let I'd put my
software on top then I could figure that
and then it was deployed and now we've
kind of got a single unit and and part
of the container metaphor sort of you
know more subsequently has become this
idea that you know you can treat a
container like a black box it has common
and your common interface to work with
that container but just like shipping
containers you don't actually have to
care too much about what's going on
inside so you know I'm deploying
containers but I don't really content
care if one of them is implemented Java
the others implemented Ruby implemented
and of course I could be having you know
different operating systems running side
those containers as long as my container
platform lets me run those types of
containers on it
I shouldn't actually care about what's
happening inside that container so for
the point of view of a deployment
activity I'm sort of further abstracted
from the detail I'm not having to get
deep in and configure a virtual machine
to run my software I'm just being given
a container and I'm going splat there is
a container I've dropped it on the
system and this is quite useful you know
with it with a shipping container all
shipping containers as common standard
shipping containers but had the same
fixing points they have the same
dimensions and what that means is you
can have a common set of tools around
and managing those containers you can
have a common pallet all right like this
it can take a contender's to built
designed to take any container that
container could contain grain it could
contain a car against pain know a bunch
of washing machines or maybe it's empty
you can either get refrigerated
containers that sit within the same
space and so by having a common
container format we also can have a
common set of tools and this is really
what docker did for us before docker we
had containers in the Linux and UNIX
operating systems but they didn't have
that common packaging contract that's
what docker gets in bed well this is how
we could packages the image we have for
a container and here's like a common set
of tools we can use to manage its
containers and although you know many
people now run containers without you
they sort of set the standard in terms
of what that format should look like and
how we should work with that so we've
gone from say physical infrastructure to
virtual infrastructure virtual
infrastructure to infrastructure as a
service having a nice API control plane
we've then gone a bit above that and
we're now thinking about Keynes as a way
to build and manage and ship our
productions but then when you start
looking at the world of the cloud there
are just so many offshoots in terms of
how you might want to go about deploying
and however you might want to go about
managing things and it can become a bit
overwhelming so I'm gonna take you
through a few examples of how we think
about deploying and managing it so if I
was in the world of say just purely the
docker and I wasn't worried about with
kubernetes Easter I just went to
containers maybe I would spin up a
virtual machine maybe an ec2 instance
and I run the docker
engine and it's a docker engine is gonna
manage the isolation between these
actually makes provisioning these
containers and managing isolation those
contained and so I could spin up
multiple instances of my service each
instance of my service or different
services could be running in different
containers all running on that same in
this case this could be a virtual
machine so I could take a physical
machine break it into virtual machines I
could then take a virtual machine and
break that up into lots of containers
and those containers from a resource
point of view are quite isolated so I
can say ok this container has this much
memory and especially CPU the isolation
isn't as strong as a virtual machine
isolation but it's still really quite
good I also get this property of uniform
deployment this is what docker gave us
was a managing containers on a single
machine but of course we want more than
one machine we might need more than one
machine to run a platform because we
want to handle more scale or because we
need to handle the failure if one of
them our VMs dies or one of our physical
machines dies we need to make sure we
still got enough instances to serve the
traffic from our customers and so there
are lots of the solutions that came out
in this space for managing contains
across multiple machines but the one
that has very much one of course has
been kubernetes so kubernetes gives you
a way of managing effective
container-based applications across
multiple machines and one of the things
it does really nicely is this property
is this thing of is this thing called
desired state management so with desired
state management you can say something
like I've got a service I want to make
sure there's at least five instances of
this service running across all the
machines I have and if one of those is
dies kubernetes has been up nothing for
you if one of the machines underneath
that dies kubernetes will also rebalance
where your services are running and
that's a really really powerful idea and
again so this is another higher more
high level abstraction rather than
having to worry about an individual
container kubernetes is just saying well
I'll deal with all the hassle of where
they're gonna run for you you didn't
have to worry about that you just tell
me how many you want and how big they
should be and I'll sort the rest for you
and you see the sort of inexorable march
this is this is the story of computing a
Cheeto developers we're always looking
for more powerful abstractions because
as we create better abstractions we get
to do more work right we get to do more
things with our time it makes us more
powerful because rather than having to
do all the time with a low-level detail
I can abstract away that detail instead
work at a higher level and get more done
you know we don't many of us I suspect
most of us do not code in machine code
anymore nor do we code at assembly code
we use higher-order programming
languages because that turns out to be
much more effective for most software
development sometimes cases where you do
when I go quite low level but most of
the time you're very happy working at
the level of sort of sort of
general-purpose programming languages
and the same is true for how we think
about working with our infrastructure
and with our sort of cloud or Clara Bay
in Sweden we might want to go quite low
level but a lot of time we're happy
being higher up and kubernetes gives us
our more highly abstracted platform for
working with containers but but when you
look really containers you say well ok
with virtual machines I take a physical
machine I break it up into virtual
machines and those virtual machines
allow me to sort of have separate
isolated execution units on the same
physical machine
well containers sort of do the same
thing in a way and you could argue that
containers
are just a maybe a better better from a
developer point of view form of
virtualization we've basically found a
way of breaking apart a set of resources
into isolated sets of resources that can
be pegged to certain processes so maybe
you know if you look at it I mean
although containers are often much
better from us from a developer point of
view they can be much more
cost-effective because it's not as
heavyweight as virtual machines they
allow us to run those containers on
laptops more easily than we might be
able to do with say VMs and things like
that they're arguably they are just a
different type of virtualization from
from that point of view but maybe more
useful one so let's talk a bit about
service and serve us a term service has
actually been around for a lot longer
than people think the originals of
definition of service as far as I have
been able to tell they've asked lots of
other people about this and they'll come
up the same answer actually comes from
an article by Ken from and so Ken wrote
the piece about the where he saw the
future of software and applications
going and he talked about it's being
serviced they actually wrote this
article back in 2012 which is sort of
interesting so he said the phrase
service doesn't mean that servers are no
longer involved it simply means that
developers no longer have to think that
much about them and what he was
reflecting on here was a whole host of
services and products that sort of
abstract away from developers the
concept of the underlying infrastructure
we don't have to work at a computer
level anymore we're working at some a
higher level of abstraction and so there
is as you know so service is talking
really about an observer right the
observer the people who use service
software they see it as having no
servers effectively that's us as
developers if you're running this on
premise of course a service stack of
some sort your developers in house might
see it as service even though you as an
Operations team might have to manage
those computers now this was articles
written about twelve but what seems to
have happened is that people have
reduced the concept of servers service -
just meaning
functions function as a service and
they're saying well when people say
service what they're actually talking
about is function as a service that's I
think it's unfortunate because I think
that really misses the point of service
service is not just about function as a
service it's about much more than that
so we've got yes function as a service
which we're going to explore in a bit
more detail in a moment but it also
encompasses database as a service
platforms think about something like
cosmos DB or dynamo DB you're not
worried about the Machine or how many
machines you have you are basically sort
of operating in a pay-as-you-go
environment you are just creating tables
and letting the platform underneath that
work out all the details
you're abstracted away from the
underlying servers it also includes
things like storage take a look at
something like AWS s3 all you do with s3
is a blob store services throw data in
you stick it in a bucket you have a hard
maybe have some instructions that bucket
if you don't have to worry about
allocating disks you don't say I'll
police add another one terabyte disk to
that you just throw the data in and
you're charged for what you use we also
have messaging products the very first
service launched by AWS was sqs in 2006
sqs is a service queue based messaging
product you don't have to manage it you
just put stuff in it comes out that's a
service product offering their second
ever products offering was AWS s3 also
launched in 2006 that was also service
so we'll though we came to see AWS as
pushing infrastructure as a service the
very first things they launched are very
much things that fit the model of
service so some was this idea that maybe
the future arrived a bit earlier than we
were ready for but there are many more
things when you look at those
cloud-based services and those cloud
offerings there are lots of different
things that fit that model if we look at
specific AWS which I know a bit better
than Azure
you know dynamodb that's a back-end as a
service Amazon s3 as blobstore service
and of course for cloud functions we
have AWS lambda so a dab if lambda so
the first of what we think of now as the
cloud function platforms that was
launched that's launched in 2014
that was two years after ken came up
with the term serving us so when we were
talking about service there was no
function as a service concept really in
widespread use so this idea that now
fast is what all services is sort of
also doubly not true but we can think
about this service product offerings
like lambda like DynamoDB like cosmos DP
like Azure cloud functions we can think
about them as just another in the step
of our another layer of abstractions in
how we work with underlying physical
resources so we can work if we want to
with the underlying physical machines
but then we started to virtualize that
infrastructure so I a virtual izing the
compute network and storage building
blocks this is where you're using vmware
or using the managed VMS maybe on your
public cloud providers and then we built
higher level abstractions on top of that
we created sort of container
orchestration as a service systems like
kubernetes or maybe we're using managed
relational database service it's like on
them AWS for example I could spin up RDS
which is a relational database service
and although I'm sort of scaling it to
an extent by a machine I say I want a
machine this big it's actually handling
a lot of the management of that machine
for me so again it's a higher level
abstraction over the management of that
database and then on top of that we've
now got even higher level extracted
services we've got the function as a
service platforms the back end as a
service platforms those messaging
products I talked to about I mean think
about is your event hub right that is a
service messaging product I've hidden
even more of the detail away from me and
I think it's arguably you know who evil
we sort of also have
platform-as-a-service stuff that sits on
top of this you know things that give
you even less control maybe but hide
even more of the detail away from what
you're able to do as we go up these
layers of abstractions we reduce the
amount of overhead that we have from a
point of view of operational management
but as we come down these layers you
have a lot more low-level access and a
lot greater control over how the system
works
so if I've got if I have direct access
to the physical machine I have a huge
amount of control over how things are
done but I've got a lot more work and so
whenever I work with teams on these
sorts of things it's like we have to
find a happy place ideally you want to
give away as much as possible right and
do as little work as you can but can you
see to that control I think often people
can give up more control than they
realized
and so I've been looking at all this
picture I sort of came to realize that I
sort of think of containers it's like a
better virtualization but I feel that
service and what service has done is
really started I don't think we're we're
entirely there yet but what we really
have done is we've created better
abstractions like better more
developer-friendly abstractions so you
know maybe we're containerization is a
better form of virtualization I think
the service products for a better for
the fraction they kind of better
developer friendly abstractions that
hide away the operational work that's
needed now you know I said very clearly
that service isn't just fast but
function as a service is one of the most
interesting features of product sets
under the service banner and I think
it's good important to explore that and
especially as what we're going to come
to is looking at these function concepts
in the context of micro services so the
way sort of fast works is when they're
quite straightforward right you've got a
developer a developer create a function
and so a function could be as simple as
something's called raising voice it
could be one method if you wanted to in
practice it might be a bit more than
that and you then deploy that onto a
fast platform so this could be power
functions this could be lamdaur whatever
else what you then do is you can
configure that function to run based on
some event so generically talk about an
event and an event could be a file being
delivered in certain bucket it could be
a page GTB request coming in over API
gateway it could be a message being
received it broker whatever
so as these events come in the the fast
platform will spin up dynamically spin
up an instance of your function to serve
that request
and you're not having to configure the
hosts he notes everything to say I want
five machines that have got you know
this much CPU that have this sign of IO
profile actually all you can really do
nearly configure with these things as
you say my function when it runs needs
this much memory and that's it and the
fat form without you being involved says
ah a request has come in about to launch
a function here's a function to serve
that request and that's done all without
you having to be involved whatsoever you
only pay for what's running so if you
have say a virtual machine running 24/7
you've got to pay for 24/7 costs with a
function you only pay if the function is
invoked if it's not invoked you don't
pay and so this can actually lead to
making some significant cost savings I
mean there's some variables around that
but you know if you've got a system that
maybe he's only used for two or three
hours a day you could deploy it as a
fast platform you don't have to worry
about turning the Machine off and on
again like a lot of people do so a lot
of people if they say only gonna use a
machine from nine till five they'll turn
it off at 8:30 in the morning they'll
turn that machine off at 5:30 in the
evening then maybe they can automate
that but it's a bit of housekeeping
you've gotta do with a function and so
platform you don't have to worry about
that if no calls are made
nothing gets launched if nothing gets
launched you don't get charged that's
really nice idea the other thing is it's
gonna handle scale for you as well as
gonna scale up and scale down as you get
more requests coming in it will
automatically spin up more instances and
you can you can limit how many instances
you allow because of course that kind of
a cost implication but for me can I get
a property right if an instance dies
another request was launched a new
instance anyway it was scale up as it
needs to and kind of importantly as that
traffic goes away it would shut those
zones down for you and they'd not need
it anymore FUNKER fast typically these
functions are designed to be short-lived
so originally you had quite short
durations for these things I think I
want to say we're lambda might have been
like five seconds or thirty seconds or
something like that
you're now up to sort of you know on the
different platforms vary but you know
sort of 15 minutes can be for some of
these but you
look exactly our platform to know how
long they run for but they are designed
to be things that kind of react to
something do the job and then shut down
again so you're not looking for long
lived processes so if you do need much
longer lived processing function as a
service probably isn't the right fit for
you under the hood the way these are
forms of working is with containers so
when you a call comes in to launch your
function but the fast platform is doing
and spitting up a container instance
running your function on here you don't
have to deal with the container that's
hidden away all you do is you give them
their you give the fast platform your
code and it deals with all that work for
you and that's a really great thing
again it's a more high-level abstraction
the containers great but can we may take
a queen could we design it in such a way
that the developer doesn't need to worry
about that container let's hide that
detail from them that's exactly what
fast does it allows a developer to just
focus on code and the operational work
is done by the platform itself
now I have mentioned some of the
constraints you typically have a
restricted execution time you also do
have somewhat limited runtime choices
now this does vary that's with the
execution time varies from platform to
platform Google Cloud for example is
really behind you know number of run
time choices then you've got JavaScript
and you've got go and I think there's I
think Java might be in beta I'm not even
sure the other two are not even sure if
if the Python stuff is out of beta yet
either as you actually got the broadest
offering in terms of different runtimes
theoretically you can run a Windows bat
file as in a Windows batch file on as a
function I mean you shouldn't but you
can you could also run things like
PowerShell scripts and functions - which
can actually quite useful sort of
maintenance administration tasks and I'd
be sitting pretty well as well but I say
as you has got the best its broadest set
of runtime choices at the moment you
also obviously have a lot less control
like it's not just that you don't have
you can't pick a programming language
you you you you have to stick to
programming languages that are supported
but you may actually only have
control over sir you might only have
access to a certain number of versions
of the runtime for example so if you've
got a function that wants to run Java 5
you probably you know that's not going
to work you're gonna have to be ready
Java 6 or Java 8 or something like that
so you also really have to rational
point of view so from a sort of the only
thing you really get to control is what
code gets run how it gets you know what
causes that code to get run and how much
memory does my function have that's kind
of it you can't do anything to configure
the underlying operating system or
anything else and also these functions
are typically considered to be pretty
much stateless so that means that an
event happens I launch my function I do
some work and that function vanishes
again when another invocation comes in
and that function gets launched again
you can't share any state from the
previous function invocation
unless you've offloaded that state to
something like a database so you can't
be holding state in memory I and this
also kind of means that so we treat
these functions of being almost entirely
stateless it's not totally true though
because there are a couple of exceptions
to this we'll come back to that a bit
later on but in general you should think
about functions as being entirely
stateless which also by the way
drastically simplifies your programming
models it makes your life much happier
if you can stick to a stateless model
for trying anyway now coming back to
micro services with minute talked a
little bit about the concept of data
ownership because this is gonna apply in
terms of how we start thinking about
function that now one of the things we
want with functions is we want this with
the services is this idea of independent
deployability so we have this idea that
a service owns its own data management
and so if another service wants to get
information if a service so the customer
service e wants to get data from the
invoicing service rather than you know
reaching straight into its database
instead you go and access that data via
some sort of well-defined interface and
the reason we want to do this is because
we want to have very clear explicit
service interfaces that we maintain
compatibility
ability of so that we can make changes
to the invoice service safely so if I
want to maybe make a change to invoicing
on a deploy I want to know that that
service interface is still compatibly my
releases if I allow people to directly
access my database and really access my
data storage it then becomes a bit of a
problem
can I change how that data storage is
done can I rename a column can I add a
new constraint and the artists we should
kind of not sure anymore because you
might break that other consumer and so
we talk about if it's eating viewing a
micro so it's like a big black box right
how the data it sort of manage is a
hidden internal implementation concern
so we don't want these sorts of that
backdoor access and I want you to hold
that thought on the back of your head
and we start thinking about how we move
into the world of functions so you know
we tend to think of a micro service like
as a collection of business
functionality hosted on a network
endpoint and you know often we package
this up as a process we put that process
into a container and we launch it so the
first question is how do I map from a
service to functions now actually in a
lot of situations you can just map them
one to one but it does depend on how big
your services but some for services that
might only do a small number of things
mapping all of your function code that
yours code into function a single
function actually is very very good
starting point and could work absolutely
fine if you want to go finer grained
than that and that's might be a common
thing is you might start to see well
actually I'm going to break all the
things that my invoicing service does
down into a series of functions well
then the kind of question is well how do
you find what what what things what
mechanisms do you use to identify which
functions you should create should I
have a hundred function should I have a
thousand functions do I take each method
in my service and make each method a
function in its own right and so you
don't want to do that you don't want to
have tens of thousands of these
functions and it's you've got a real
need if you do decide you want to go
finer grains than one service or one
function
the piece of advice I'd give is to start
looking for how you work and manage your
sort of aggregate so your bits of data
so this so that's an initial starting
point would be to map the all the
functionality about managing a single
aggregate to being one function
initially at least so inside by
invoicing service we might work with and
manage say an invoice aggregate and
account aggregate and order aggregate so
these sort of represent you know things
with identity things with state and do
you see also see consent have lifecycle
associated with them and if you look at
your service is pretty lots of things
that are aggregates that you might
manage within a service boundary and so
if you know you're gonna start mapping
these into functions a good place to
start I say well actually we're gonna do
is I'm gonna take all the code for
managing an invoice and I'm going to
create a function for managing that
invoice aggregate and so any calls
related to changing that invoice get
handled by my function and this is where
the word function kind of gets a bit
amorphous because all really you've got
with these things we talked about
deploying a function what you're doing
is really deploying a package of code
and you have one of those functions
which is your entry point for execution
so when you're HTTP calc think it's
called it's going to hit a function in
the top of your function bundle that
function could call other functions so
there's no reason why you couldn't have
one single entry point for all invoicing
functionality for example and have an
handle the whole life cycle around
invoice
single function boundary by keeping all
of the code associated with managing a
single aggregate in a single function it
becomes much easier to make sure you're
properly implementing the state machine
around that aggregate and so if I have
three aggregates here maybe if I go find
a grain I may be looking initially at my
invoicing service now actually testing
of three separate functions now I saw
now I'm getting into finer grained
deployment so now I could update in Chow
the other side of the invoicing is done
and just deploy that function by itself
which is you know kind of useful now if
you're moving from say deploying your
your service
one big unit two now moving it towards
lots of little functions you also have
to give sort of jus thought to what's
happening for people outside of your
service boundary and my advice here
would be that if you're deciding it's a
big service down into smaller functions
that you still try to hide that from the
outside world so if the points of view
of your consumers they think they're
still talking to an invoicing service
but behind the scenes what actually
happens when these calls come in is
they're just being dispatched these
individual functions so from the outside
world they think a single invoicing
micro service exists from an internal
implementation detail point of view
though you're implementing that
invoicing service in terms of lots of
little functions and that's that sort of
you want to hide that implementation
detail because you might change your
mind about how these functions deployed
you might decide you know what I don't
want to have twenty functions I'm gonna
go back to one or I don't want to get
rid of functions and go back in this is
a container on kubernetes
and if you've kept the external
interface the same you can do that
safely without impacting your kind of
customers and yeah well not your
customers your consumers which are
nearly always going to be your own
colleagues who are calling your service
from something else that's good last
about talk this talks about the outside
world
but what about you know about the
database right so if I've broken my
invoicing service down into say three
functions from edging three different
aggregates or I broken it down even
further maybe I've broken down a state
transition into a separate function
which you which is what you can do if I
take it to the extreme degree then well
how does that work in terms of accessing
my data at my database because we sort
of said before that we don't want lots
of things accessing the same database
except courses coupling this is
something we've got to consider because
I mean once service because something
was all in three five ten fifteen twenty
functions and all of those functions are
sort of all accessing the same database
that starts to look a little bit like
having lots of services talking to the
same database he said we didn't want to
do that because that creates coupling
between the functions and the reality is
if you're breaking functions down to be
individual state transition
on aggregate then those functions are
inherently coupled anyway so what I tend
to try and think about this as I say
look these functions implement this
service to these 5 10 15 20 functions
they all would in the invoicing service
the invoicing service manages a set of
data and so as long as you kind of have
that idea that logical association
between the functions and the service
then you can still have this working
quite happily right so you can kind of
think of now rather than one service
owning the data now you've got a logical
set of functions which implement the
service which own the same data so my
invoicing service which consists of lots
of functions has I still can all access
the same set of data because they all
have seen conceptions the whole thing
there were ok by the same team for
example if you start seeing that
different people are working on
different functions a lot that might
give you cause when I try to call those
functions out of the invoicing service
per se you might also want to pull that
data out well now where these things get
confusing in the world of service of
course is that the data bases in in this
world are a little bit different you
know we think about a relational
database we have typically with a
relational database we have the idea of
a schema so one relational database
instance can support multiple different
logically isolated database schemas so I
can have you know my invoicing schema as
all of my invoicing data is inside that
invoicing schema and I can control who
accesses that invoicing schema and that
invoicing schema is owned by me the
invoicing service and so that kind of
idea of that of logically isolated data
set is kind of really useful in the
world of relational databases and other
non relational databases to but when you
start looking at the world service
databases there those abstractions
aren't necessarily there and there's
just so many more options right so when
I'm thinking about Azure I've got table
storage I've got a cosmos DB on Google
Cloud I've got a big table I got spanner
I've got datastore on AWS it's simple D
be dumpy I've got a drawer service and
these are just a subset of the service
datastore option database option right
there right these are just the first you
know eight I could find now in reality
the list is a bit shorter than that
because no one uses a table store which
was simple DB anymore but you know it's
there's still a lot of options out there
so you're gonna have to pick if you want
a service database that actually kind of
having that nice property of not having
to measure detail you know you you could
have to work and assess these different
options out there or or service is quite
different DynamoDB or or service on
database is much more akin to a
relational database than dynamo DB is
dynamo DB looks a lot more like a
document database it's closer to a
document database like I would say
as its accomplished cosmos cosmos and
dynamo DB a kind of a similar-looking
databases and so that's that these
databases have those from different
characteristics so on dynamo DB do for
example on cosmos DB I don't concept of
a schema with a set of tables in it that
can be locked down what I actually have
is I have a table now these tables in
dynamo DB and cosmos DB aren't like a
table in a relational data store they're
much more like a dough base you can
imagine like a JSON document right right
but can have multiple nested columns
inside it and so often you don't need
multiple tables store your data you
might get away storing all of it in one
table that has sort of bit more
complexity around it so here's my
invoicing functions using stuff from the
invoicing table and I've call so got a
customer table over here and my issue
invoice function needs invoicing data
and it needs customer data okay so I've
got a customer table I've got an
invoicing table that's fine okay but
I've also got some stuff for managing
customers and they need to talk to the
customer table and it starts to look a
bit like messy right it starts to look
like we could be getting back in the
world of everybody'll accessing anybody
else's data
because remember we still want this idea
of so logically isolating our different
service boundaries so here well I've got
you say team a look exhaust fitting
service and team B looks after the
customer service and the customer
service manages that customer data this
issue tis a function shouldn't be
directly accessing somebody else's data
that's not what we want right because
this is just as bad as one service
reaching into another services database
the key thing here is though that these
different tables are I have you know
others if you've created them both on
the same account they're both available
you can just go read them you can go
view them if you want to what you
actually have to do is sort of you have
to yourself put in place that idea of
the of the sort of schema type
abstraction over the top of it because
what we really want to do is say okay
what I've got is my black box which is
my invoicing functionality and on my
black box which is my customer
functionality and if I want to go
between those black boxes rather than
going through the direct access to
somebody else's table I still should go
to a function so I shouldn't if I need
to customer data I might go and use the
appropriate function to access that
customer data now that the challenge is
because we lack this logical abstraction
of the schema with things like dynamodb
and cosmos DB limiting access is
something that you end up kind of doing
either at the account level or using
access roles so you could actually
create an access role for the invoice
service which can only see the invoicing
table or an access role for the customer
service that can only see the customers
table so I've done this before by using
effectively prefixes on table names and
applying that as part of the identity
access management rules so this role the
invoicing role can see all dynamodb
table is to start with the prefix
invoice - and then that way you can kind
of get some level of grouping that's a
bit of work you have to do yourself to
create those abstractions
I did say earlier that these functions
are typically stateless that's not
there's sort of not quite true
there's AWS everything called state
front there step functions now step
functions don't really let you have
functions themselves which have state
but it does allow you to pass state from
one function to another if you look at
step functions work you basically kind
of create designs maybe the wrong word
but a step functions gives you a way of
sort of sequencing a whole bunch of
lambda functions they get executed in a
certain order when one function finishes
it passed the state on to the next
function it looks a lot like a workflow
management tool or BPM I'm actually a
bigger fan of Azure durable functions
which i think is a much smarter
developer friendly approach whereas step
functions often as you end up wading
through huge amounts of Jason to
coordinate multiple functions working
together with durable functions it
basically hooks into reactive extensions
so I can be I have a right piece of
c-sharp code and I could say okay well I
want to go and execute a function now so
I can go and say here's I'm gonna do an
async await on this other function
invocation and what happens when that
async away execute is that your function
gets suspended it executes the other
function once the other function is
completed it comes back it starts your
function up again and the results of
that are passed back to you so it's sort
of stateful but that the word state with
all is sort of is it interesting it sort
of has very specific meaning what's
actually happening beneath the hood if
you've ever looked at things like
continuations and that's basically what
the durable function stuff is working
it's really really interesting now at
the moment I think it's only officially
supported for c-sharp on Azure but then
Microsoft has said that they are going
to roll out durable function support for
all the languages they support so it
there's a I think the Java doable
function stuff is in beta at the moment
so it's well worth looking at if you're
looking to build more complex flows and
I like the idea of keeping that stuff in
code rather than sort of having to push
it out to some sort of separate Jason
type
a structure because it becomes hard to
see how things hang together whereas
with durable functions you've actually
got half a chance of like actually
following the code flow and the flow
between its functions within the scope
of just by observing by sort of walking
through your code I've mostly so far
been talking about on-premise sort of
thought as a public cloud based services
and the reality is that the service
offerings are significant public cloud
and are very very very poor on private
cloud part of that is because a bunch of
the sort of the are the things that the
service products do behind the scenes is
just working with things that are
difficult right like lots of file
servers and all these sorts of things so
we don't really have something as good
as Amazon s3 that runs on premise
because the initial outlays in costs are
just enormous right you don't get to say
I'm just gonna store a gigabyte in a
blob store I only want to pay 10 cents
an hour because step one in implementing
an on premise blob store you know
involves giving a seven finger chips and
their app for a big filer or sand to sit
somewhere in your data center so there's
some challenges there but there's
something like function as a service
there are open source frameworks out
there to give you fast light
capabilities you can look at something
like open fast
for example which the framework that you
run on top of kubernetes they can give
you that sort of function invocation
type experience it's not as fully
featured as the fast platforms that
exist for on a zero or on AWS but you
know it's still a good approximation of
that we've also seen Google are moving
towards this thing called K native and
so K native is going to embrace this
idea of fast type implementations and
other types of service products that you
could run on top of any kubernetes
platform the idea being you could go
from kubernetes platform to kubernetes
platform and have access to some common
service type offerings the one caveat I
would say about Kay native is that it's
quite early on in its evolution Google
have decided to take K native private
inter
it's evolution they're not developing
that specification in the open like they
did with kubernetes they're gonna own
that then drive that themselves and
Google's
track record in in kind of getting
technology to a point where it's stable
enough for use as in you're not getting
lots of churn and change hasn't been
great it took a long time for kubernetes
stabilized sto is still not stabilized
and Kay native is being built on top of
this do so maybe k native will be the
future I don't really think it's going
to be the present for many of us because
even if maybe it works now they might
quite completely redesign it in six
months from now and yeah we'd have to
expect that to happen now if you're
interested in playing around with any of
this stuff I think if you want to see
this sort of really appreciate how
powerful function as a service can be I
think you spend half a day half a day
playing around it pick a cloud platform
of your choice and and start working
with it now the out-of-the-box
experience for setting up functions on
these things is a lot worse than it
should be and that's why I tend to point
people towards a tool like the service
framework so the service framework gives
you a really nice command-line interface
for packaging your software deploy it
onto these cloud platforms executing
them from your you know fax your
terminal you can pull down the logs you
can you can rollback versions and
everything it's a really really nice
tool chain for working with function as
a service on you know sort of AWS cloud
Google Cloud or Azure theoretically its
platform agnostic right so the command
line is kind of platform agnostic so you
almost don't care from a command line
point of view if you're talking to
Amazon or Azure for your function but
the reality is it's not as simple as
saying I could just dynamically run
those functions and either place more
configuration than that but it is well
worth a look and and and I think that
the nice thing about the service
framework is it's also it supports lots
of different programming languages some
of these sorts of service SDKs out there
a specific to certain platforms like you
get ones that are just for node
functions you get ones that just Python
functions you can go straight to the
underlying cloud platform if you can go
and use their consoles and stuff to do
your stuff with a graphical user tools I
would urge you to
start with the service framework just
initially because what you do is you can
configure your function using a bit of
code you can have it checked in you can
fully automate your function creation
deployment management and development
life cycles from the beginning and that
just that workflow is just so nice it's
definitely worth taking a look at the
service framework spend two hours at
some point this week over the weekend
you create a couple of functions play
around with them and you'll just get
start to get a sense of just how awesome
they can be from a developer point of
view so just to summarize you know we
think about service we should put
service in the context of this
continuing drive towards having more and
more powerful abstractions creating
higher and higher order abstractions
over underlying infrastructure that
allows us as developers to get more
stuff done I think the current crop of
service offerings may not be the future
I think there are better things to come
I don't think they've really delivered
on them full promises of this stuff yet
but they are well worth exploring for
many of the organizations I'm chatting
to who are looking to move to the cloud
I'm suggesting you know what maybe
rather than trying to kubernetes fire
your application maybe I should start
looking to see if some this stuff could
be functions instead use go straight to
a native fast platform it can open up
some you know significant benefits I
mean above all all the server stuff is
by abstracting away more and more detail
from me it's empowering me more as a
developer to get more things done myself
which in turn is gonna help this drive
towards independent deployability so in
summary serverless think of service like
more developer-friendly abstractions
it's allowing us to do more to sort of
own more responsibility without having
to do more work it's making us more
productive as a result functions can map
really nicely to microservice boundaries
you start thinking of your function you
have a one-to-one mapping from a micro
service to a single function we're going
to break it down further you can go from
the aggregate to function trigger even
further again you can go from the state
transitions of an aggregate down to a
function as well but just if you're
going to do all these if you're gonna
start having lots of functions still
have this overall arching idea of a
collection of
that worked closely together and keeping
data ownership within that sort of
logical service boundary I've got a
bunch more stuff on service over my
website I've got a video I did for Riley
that you can watch as part of their
online learning platform I've also got
other talks on this stuff over on my
website as well which I'm easy to find
on the internet but thanks so much for
listening along we have got some we've
had been having questions open on slide
oh so I'm just going to spin that up on
my iPad it's trying to do face ID but
I've got my headset on so it's getting
confused so I should see if we've got
any questions have come in on slide oh
I'm just gonna open that up again and
refresh that so while I'm opening up
slide oh this is a chance for you to ask
any questions so there's a little bit of
a delay 8 6 0 okay let's take a quick
look here we go
this is a good question here from Eric
some Eric says I didn't catch you say
much about performance taking containers
up and down sounds like a lot of
overhead especially in cascades of
east-west calls
so what Merrick is talking about really
here is what some people have described
as the as a cold spin up so a request
comes in and I have to launch a
container to serve the request coming in
now the time taken to cold start a
container like that could be quite long
it relatively speaking if you're working
in a programming language like Java or
or c-sharp the the nature of those
runtimes mean that have a bit of a
longer ramp up time if you're working
with something like Python nodejs
go they spin up much much faster so how
quickly a cold spin up occurs is gonna
vary from platter from run time to run
time so if you have to have very very
fast spin up time so that's something
you might take to take into account the
other thing is that the the underlying
fast platforms are going through huge
amounts of optimizations to keep that
cold spin uptime as low as possible
they're doing lots of things about sort
of optimizing things at the JVM and the
CLR to improve those spin up times you
might look into things like the
firecracker VMs and stuff like that the
Amma's are doing to to make those things
that contain it invocation even faster
their third things going on here is it's
very rare you actually get a cold spin
up so what actually happens so certainly
I know this happens on AWS I'm not I'm
less sure about how it works on this
year is Amazon actually keeps a sort of
live copy of your container knocking it
keeps it around so although it's not
executing once the function stops
executing it leaves that container where
it is but it's in a dormant state and so
in the end though that execution comes
in they divert it to an already launched
container instance I said it's like it
shuts down again because of the point of
view of the function the function does
shutdown again it does vanish you know
you don't have any state between those
functions but actually they can to the
runtime that held that function can be
kept hold of by the underlying cloud
platform and so that she that might and
I might keep that around for hours
and so you it's very rare that you'll
see a full cult spin up time if you
wanna see more just check so what you
might want to do is to take a look I'm
just taking a look
yes oh really interesting posts out
there I can certainly see let me just
put a link on the cloud share though if
the thing to search for is cold start up
time or cold start time there is a just
an article I read a while ago that might
be a bit out of date this is they W a
specific but it goes a little bit into
some of the detail around these spin up
times so
so you might be interested in reading
this article on how AWS does it this is
actually somebody from the outside in
trying to look at how how long those
things are kept live for it also talks
about the link between memory size and
spin up that's the other thing you do
live thing about aspect around
performance is you can sometimes see a
bit of variation in performance when you
give a function a smaller amount of
memory so like 128 256 Meg's what you
will often see is Amazon will actually
and Isis you may do it as I say as you
it is the same so AWS said okay well I'm
gonna give you at least 256 Meg and
that's also a proxy for how much for CPU
you get but if it's more spate that most
performance available to you they'll let
you use extra capacity so what you'll
see is with the smaller function sizes
you'll see a bit of variability in in
how quickly those functions execute
whereas actually if you want guaranteed
far throughput you often better picking
a larger memory size as well and that
tends to relay to the underlying machine
having been IO so there's so this is but
the only level of control you have is
that is that actual memory footprint the
person to follow on this for AWS anyway
is Yan Sui who's there so Yan's also the
burning monk online this is actually one
of his blog posts he's done so much work
in this space for AWS I'm sure you'll
find other in the Microsoft world I'm
sure there are some great MVPs out there
that can help share knowledge with you
about how this works on Azure but I hope
that makes sense and this is like I
talked about in more detail on that I
Reilly close okay now let's see have I
still got my as slides up I can see any
other questions
[Music]
so I think I've got all the questions
done I appreciate that
I hope the lines been good enough for
you and you've been able to hear me if
they've got any other questions for me
best thing to do in the real conference
well you could grab me in the corridor
we can have a chat we can't do that here
so I would say Jess just ping me on
Twitter I'm just at Sam Newman on
Twitter and as I said there's a whole
load of information about all the kinds
of the work I do and books and all sorts
of other things over on my website so I
hope you'll find something of interest
to you and I hope you enjoy the rest of
your day
you